vemos que en el triángulo ay sabemos que
en el triángulo hay tres ángulos en el
caso de un triángulo rectángulo como el
que he dibujado aquí uno de ellos será
de 90 grados entonces tenemos otros dos
ángulos de los cuales encargarnos y lo
que quiero explorar en este vídeo es la
relación entre el seno de uno de estos
ángulos y el coseno del otro el coseno
de uno de estos ángulos y el seno del
otro
para poder hacer esto digamos que este
ángulo que llamaremos ángulo a digamos
que es igual a teta
si este es igual a theta si su medida es
teta grados
digamos cuál será la medida del ángulo b
bueno pues lo primero que les llegará a
la mente será que vivimos esto en otros
problemas es que la suma de los ángulos
será 180 grados y este de aquí es un
triángulo recto por lo que este ángulo
recto se lleva a 90 de esos 180 grados
entonces nos quedan 90 grados por lo que
estos dos deberán de sumar 90 grados
este y este ángulo a y ángulo b se
complementarán entre ellos van a ser
complementarios u otra manera de verlo
es que ve puede ser escrito como 90
- teta
si uno le suma teta a 90 z vamos a
obtener vamos a obtener o teta más 90
grados menos teta vamos a obtener 90
grados y por qué es esto interesante
pensemos pensemos en que es el seno
a que es igual el seno de eta
se no es opuesto sobre la hipotenusa el
lado opuesto
entonces esta será la longitud del
segmento d
sobre la hipotenusa
la hipotenusa ese lado ap
entonces la longitud de veces sobre la
longitud de ave avn
sobre la longitud de ave ahora cuál
sería la relación si estuviéramos
viéndolo desde la perspectiva de este
ángulo bueno pues para el ángulo de ese
es el lado adyacente y ave es la
hipotenusa desde la perspectiva del
ángulo b este es el lado adyacente sobre
la hipotenusa y cuál es la relación
trigonométricas de adyacente sobre
hipotenusa pues esa es coseno soca tohá
déjenme escribir esto
se no es su puesto sobre hipotenusa lo
podemos ver aquí coseno es adyacente
sobre hipotenusa acá sitúa tangente es
opuesto sobre adyacente entonces desde
la perspectiva de este ángulo tomando la
longitud dps donde desde ese lado
adyacente la hipotenusa sigue siendo ave
entonces desde la perspectiva de este
ángulo
esto es adyacente sobre hipotenusa u
otra manera de verlo es el co seno de
este ángulo entonces esto será igual a
el coseno
el coche no de 90 grados menos zeta
y esta es una relación muy sencilla el
seno de un ángulo es igual al coseno de
su complemento una manera de ver esto es
el seno
digamos tomemos un valor al azar el seno
de 60 grados
será igual al coseno de que y los invito
a detener el vídeo y pensar en la
respuesta será el coseno
90 - 60 será el coseno de 30 grados
30 60 90 y por supuesto uno puede
hacerlo de la manera contraria podemos
pensar en el coche no
de teta
será igual
al lado adyacente dt está bueno debería
decir del ángulo a el lado adyacente
está aquí este es hace
entonces será hace sobre la hipotenusa
adyacente sobre la hipotenusa la
hipotenusa es a
ve
pero cuál es esta relación desde la
perspectiva del ángulo b pues el seno
del ángulo b el seno del ángulo que será
a su lado opuesto se hace sobre la
hipotenusa a b entonces esto de aquí
desde la perspectiva del ángulo b
este es el seno del ángulo b entonces
esto es igual a esto es igual al seno
90 grados menos z
entonces el coseno de un ángulo es igual
al seno de su complemento el seno de un
ángulo es igual al coseno de su
complemento